[Music]
this guy is
keep his promise but failed to keep his
promise to keep the followers I'm
telling you in 355 where he says and 61
verse 14 where he says I will make those
who follow you above the disbelievers
until the day of judgment yeah which is
the Muslim
S
as well okay I got you but you're saying
that the Muslims at some point failed
that the disbelievers conquered the the
Believers in their message right in
their Creed how did they fail Islam
Islam is here right now yeah but so 600
years later Islam came to correct what
was distorted by the disbelievers right
no Islam was always here really
so Muhammad was the first Muslim of his
time just as Moses was just as Jesus was
just as all the prophets were Islam
existed from the time of Adam okay I I
know what you're saying so you're saying
that the musl they were the real
Believers of Jesus were Muslims I got
that my question to you is this did the
disbelievers at any point successfully
deter distort and alter the message of
Jesus yes or no yes they alter the
message the message of Jesus but that
doesn't negate Muslims existing because
I didn't say them until today Muslims
even existed before the time of the road
before the time I understand what I'm
saying but Islam simply means submission
to God
Omar understand what I'm saying I am not
saying that I'm going with you I'm not
saying that Muslims ceased to exist I'm
saying that the Muslims of that time the
True Believers of Jesus that you're
saying there were Muslims you're saying
failed at some point and was under the
disbelievers the disbelievers became
above the actual Believers at some point
until Islam came to correct right
okay so what does the verse say it says
that the Muslims will be superior over
the over the disbelievers yes it no it
says no it says that the followers of
Jesus will be superior above the
disbelievers until the day of judgment
yeah Superior to what sense
Superior in the sense that uh the the
message will be kept and in the form of
battle whenever they go into battle with
them they will also be successful at
court that's what the tough series is
the message of Islam here today
uh it is today but it wasn't it wasn't
no no that's all my question is if he
wants to answer my question yes then
it's finished sure
thank you very much alhamdulillah so the
Muslims are Superior until the day of
judgment thank you no no appreciate it
because yes
Omar Omar
relax man stop relax so Omar so at some
point though the the disability
can you guys relax
no need to do that hominins yet just
don't worry yeah they did just they just
trying to decide
I'm here I'm here it's all right
sausage as well
so Omar Omar so at some point though the
disbelievers were above the Believers
right
in what sense in the sense that they
conquered and actually distorted the
message of the real Believers okay so
distorting the message of the the engine
which is the Revelation not a book a
revelation sent to him doesn't mean that
the Muslims want to Superior over them
okay so my simple question is Islam here
today no hold on hold on that's not true
what you just said that just because
they successfully distorted the message
of Jesus the Revelation that they be
that they were above the the actual
Believers now they were about that means
that they were above the Believers when
you read it because there and you read
jellal Lane read the top series on this
they really yes they say that when the
when Allah says that the Believers will
be uppermost against the disbelievers
that um that that's this means in in uh
that they will successfully get help
from Allah in conveying the message of
Jesus
and also that they're supposed to be
successful in in an argument and by the
sword okay let's see let's see what epic
Theory says when Allah said Muhammad
those believed in him also believed in
Allah his angels books and Messengers in
the correct manners so they were the
truth
they believed in the unlisted Prophet
the final messenger and the master of
all mankind who called them to believe
in the truth in its entirety
huh what do you mean yes yeah these are
the followers of Mohammed right these
are the true these are the true
followers
exactly so we're the two followers what
happened before Muhammad dude we're the
true followers did Islam cease to exist
the Islam sees to exit before the
prophet Muhammad
according to according to you guys Yes
No it didn't
really so Islam always existed from the
time of Adam there was always people
submitting the world okay so what are
those Muslims what does Islam meaning my
friend what does Islam mean do you know
you're not dealing you're not dealing
with the question what does Islam mean
what does Islam mean did the Muslims
listen to the question bro just answer
me
don't answer my questions
no you're running what is it those
Muslims that
existence you're not answering the
question don't be slaughtered don't be
scared this is what you usually this is
what you guys really it says you you
dismissed here is this Muhammad's
religion shall always be dominant and
Victorious over all others there at all
you skipped look at the miscoting that
you did look at them it's quoting it
says
religion shall always be dominant in
Victorious all over all religions oh so
wait so what happened okay so so the the
dominance begins after Muhammad
Islam still existed even the time after
uh no he answered the question does the
dominance begin after Muhammad or does
it begin before Muhammad no even before
Islam still exists okay thank you so
were they died it was always there bro
it was always look the guy's not
answering my question did Islam ever
cease to exist what is wrong with you
did Islam always cease to exist what is
wrong with it did it ever cease to exist
yes it wasn't always there okay you guys
are saying pay attention to the claim so
I want you to answer my questions
address my question you guys are
addressed my question no address my
question did Islam ever cease to exist
amazing yeah
so you're so nervous that you can't even
deal with the argument you didn't answer
anything you didn't answer me my
question did you
always dominant yes or no
yes they were they were Islam never
ceased to exist how does season two
exist incur dominance you're literally
you're not dealing with the argument
what are you talking about just because
you're not dominant does not mean you
cease to exist there's a lot of groups
exist in the world today but they're not
dominant doesn't doesn't matter Islam
never cease
you're not dominant okay the only group
okay then the only group that can
existed
those who believed in him also so those
who believed in him when Allah
this is funny because what he's doing is
he's quitting he's quoting the later
paragraph of Vivica Theory I'm about to
pull it up myself too by the way and
show you where uh says what I'm talking
about but so not only is he uh uh uh
well let's go with his understanding
according to him the true Muslims the
True Believers was when Islam came was
when Muhammad came so my question is
what happened to the True Believers
before him
were they dominant
done done no he's he's not he's not on
screen ask her a question again ask your
question again
where is he not even there right now
he's probably got a phone call oh we're
just gonna try to get a w when someone's
on the on the bed until he gets back
I'll wait till he's like playing
basketball and then like someone goes to
the bench and you score and you look at
him be like that's all on you bro I got
you well get on the cards don't run to
the best stay on the course
so and with a True Believer before
Muhammad Omar were they dominant yes or
no
yes they were and the reason why the
tafsir of this verse look The Exodus of
this verse according to chapter 16 verse
44. look you're just taking even kefir
you know you don't read any other yeah
wait the Christians the Christians were
what they were closer to the religion of
asadai Cinema why because they believed
in one God
did they not
were they the dominant they were closer
in that sense and they believed in Jesus
as the professor were they dominant oh
my battery is about to die hold up
hold up hold up
get the charger were they dominant
answer the question yes they were
because they believed in the original
message of Jesus wait oh my goodness
this is amazing well you're Paul well
your paw was slicing heads off
oh so wait so Paul was able to not only
win by the sword but was also able to
infiltrate the belief and Theology and
no they're still Superior regardless
they're still Superior regardless and
regardless of what if they still exist
they're still Superior
simple no just because you exist makes
you Superior
yes it is
you keep conflating terms it's just
because you exist does that make you
Superior Islam destroys your paganism so
yes it does Omar I mean you could you
can keep saying that but you're not
answering the question
yes the simple fact that you exist when
it comes to slam since you guys are
pagans it makes a superior people we're
asking a very simple question that you I
just answered you I just answered you
you refuse to answer it you want me to
answer a specific way I already answered
is is it existing is is existing and
antecedent to being Superior
no not not in a general sense but when
it comes to this sense okay okay so just
because also just because you exist Does
it make you Superior okay guys
it's a very simple question to you in
your reviews I said I said in a general
sense in a general sense it doesn't when
it comes to Islam it does
among the disbelievers can I can I get
the screen Greg
and the extra juice and and the tests
here for all all the other toughest here
say that the Christians were closer to
the religion of Asa than the Jews
because they didn't reject him as the
Messiah
appreciate it all right now watch this
so this is toughs here right now let's
see how he explains this is chapter 61
verse 14. how he breaks this down and
then watch this y'all okay so right here
we are helpers of Allah right because uh
this is where Jesus asked who who will
support me
hold on let me uh make sure I get all
this angles right oh here it is who will
support me in conveying the message of
Allah right the exalted and honor yada
yada
right
we are helpers of Allah meaning
where am I at all right meaning we will
support you with regards to the message
you have been sent with and will help
you convey it so what was the job of the
disciples
to help spread the message of Jesus and
to convey it
and then it's because there says whereby
Isa sent the disciples to the various
areas of Ashan what is this website
this is chronix.com
no it's okay we don't we don't take what
ondex.com but it's okay
here guys watch he's gonna say that you
guys don't take nothing you don't take
nothing he's gonna say that Paul was a
messenger thrown on the bus yeah because
they're thrown under the bus
all right so watch this so the disciples
were supposed to convey the message and
spread the message and I and then and it
says Allah help them watch so
da da
uh where's the verse that okay here it
is then a group of the children of
Israel believed in a group disbelieved
right
so we gave power to those who believed
against the enemies
that gave them victory over the group of
Christians which defied them so the ones
who disbelieved the ones who went astray
right so according to this they are
successful and Allah gave them victory
in conveying the message and and and
spreading the message
but you want to say that Paul and the
rest of the people
successfully
um distorted the message
so how does this work out
was Allah successful and did he keep his
promise or did Paul overcome Allah
yes they are superior still let's read
the verse
we already did it says what it says he
will give you another favor that you
long for the help from Allah and the
imminent Victory so give good to the
good news to the Believers
the next verse Oh Believers stand up for
Allah as Jesus Son of Mary asked the
disciples who will stand up for me for
Allah the disciples reply we will stand
up for Allah that our group from the
children of Israel believed while
another disbelieved we supported the
Believers against their enemies so they
prevailed
so what do you understand by this verse
uh clearly that Allah made them
successful in conveying their their uh
their beliefs and the message every
single one of the Muslims every single
one every single one of them excuse me
wait wait what is wrong with every
single one of the Muslims or just the
disciples can I finish answering your
question
yeah thank you what the verse means is
that Allah successfully gave them power
over the disbelievers in spreading the
message and conveying the message that
the Heretics that tried to come up Allah
and they were able to smash everything
every uh everybody
now watch this guys this was while this
was this while Jesus was on Earth or
after
uh both no it's what does it say both
because they're helpers of Allah right
no it says
this is during his time on Earth let me
show you let's try it let me show you
what does it say
chapter three verse 55 hold on let me go
to it
just got busted man
watch this watch I got busted guys watch
when I get there you said it was while
he was on earth right just watch when I
get the big screen watch when you get
the victory
all right watch this let me uh let's get
the verse
okay it says
when God said to Jesus I will take you
to myself and exalt you and rid you of
the infidels and hold those
who follow you
above those who disbelieve till the day
of Resurrection wait when will this
happen Omar
when Allah will take that's not even the
translation that's not even the
translations
show the translation actually actually
you're right because the translation
really is he's reading the Arbury
translation just let him finish guys
just let him finish I'm going to put him
on the crosstalk guys I'm gonna put them
on the crossover let's just watch this
I'm actually using off and Ali are you
blind that's when I was using really let
him finish but you're right though uh
Central the the the right uh translation
is uh I will cause you to die and take
you to an exhaust no it's nothing
no no no don't let him jump don't let
him jump don't let him jump don't let
him just let him jump don't let him jump
just let them finish it yeah so there we
go so when will this happen when will he
make them uh above those who disbelieve
when will this happen
what's going on
what's going on I don't know oh my God
it says bro it says yeah I know I know
that's why that's what I just said
that's what I just said wait hold on
check your brother though the one who's
interrupting who doesn't know what he's
talking about checking you know exactly
what I'm talking about your dog logic
bro what are you talking about
um
is it all right nobody's nervous guys
just let him finish I'm gonna put him on
the cross after this
so Omar according to this
when will Allah hold those who who
followed him above the disbelievers is
it when Jesus is here on Earth or is it
till the day of judgment till the day of
judgments from that time I answered you
in this verse let's talk about the day
of judgment no no no wait hold on the
day of judgment until the day of
judgment right yes till day of judgment
so even when Jesus let's see what 61 14.
wait wait before you go in that verse no
in that verse no that's after Jesus
that's after Jesus that's after Jesus
leaves that's after Jesus that's after
Jesus went up okay all right okay good
go ahead watch this
yo I'm not gonna lie right now I gotta
energize like intermission right at the
movie theater you gotta go and get some
popcorn hey my wife made this Curry oh
my gosh I might have to put this thing
on mute and go eat me some you know what
I mean it smells it's about a slap just
like this this slap he's about to get he
said in 61-14 he said in 61-14 is
talking about when he's it's not talking
about when he's on Earth I said who will
support me why are you lying you said
you did say that you lie
okay
and this verse you did not say both do
not lie you did not say both in this
verse was this while Jesus was on Earth
or after
uh both both
no it's what does it say both who will
support me in conveying the message of
my Lord verily have prevented me from
conveying the message of my Lord let's
go down let's go down while he's on
earth a group of the children of Israel
believed in a group disbelieved when Isa
conveyed the message of his Lord to his
people and the disciples supported him a
group of the children Israel believed so
this is talking about why he's on Earth
355 is talking about after he leaves
after after he leaves and his followers
will be superior to the day of judgment
I don't know finished Victory to the
believing group so we gave power to
those who believed again I literally
said that we gave them victory of the
group of the Christians which defied
them yes I literally said that so and
they they're literally
living group
boom
but did you just say address it you
literally made a dress address no I
didn't I you said this verse 61-14 is
talking about are you telling me after
you said why are you telling me to
address you did not say both you're
cutting me off at 61-14 you did not say
both why why are you so nervous that
you're cutting me off thank you
so we just listened to you no
interruptions we let you do that so so
so watch this
the first time he asked me wait so uh uh
when when did this when does this happen
when does Allah uh make them Victorious
is it is it when he's on Earth or is it
after
impersonation both I literally said both
and these are over vote no no see now
I'm about to crush you so then I showed
him where it's it happens afterwards and
he just quoted the verse where it
happens while he's there on Earth as
well it's both when he's on the earth
and after he leaves the Earth
so you you literally making my point
you're saying boom and dropping the mic
this is what you guys have to do 61-14
was only one you said 61 14 was only one
61 14 goes with 355. do you disagree
with that
well 61 14 is always on Earth at 355 is
afterwards okay I we we're in agreements
dude no one's is is arguing that here's
the point now the point is is that the
Believers of Jesus guess what are
supposed to be above the disbelievers
how so in the fact that they conveyed
the message correctly and spread it no
you didn't no you didn't even know I
told you that you don't even know who
authored your Bible I showed you that
that's the that's the that's the problem
the problem is he's assuming that wait
hold on hold on
so is anybody so is anybody gonna refuse
what I'm saying yeah yeah can we just go
to 512 and 513 and it'll refute your
whole arguments
okay 13. ruined here guys just look at
all the other toughest here all the
others here say what say the Christians
were Superior why because they they
believed in Jesus the Jews did not
believe in Jesus the Christians believed
in Jesus so they are superior do you
give me the big screen uh again um Greg
pull up
wants it
okay I have something to show them
because because he said let's let's see
what the other top series say yeah let's
I agree let's see what the other top
seers say about this is it this one that
I'm looking at
uh bro's about to pull a job while Lane
watch there's a 61-14 let's see here
yeah jealous Lane I like yellow Lane man
I can give you proof for that watch what
jelly Lane says we don't take jelly they
don't accept it we don't accept that
stop doing it wow
you are not gonna believe what almost
just happened
everybody
yeah
excuse me excuse me excuse me show me my
goodness oh my goodness relax fellas all
right well if you're gonna you're not
gonna get the screen if you're gonna
show some we don't give me the screen
real quick
to you yeah
don't worry no no hold on hold on hold
on and God logic when we're done we're
gonna bring the book of The Gospel of
Barnabas next you're okay if we use that
even though you don't believe in that
one right that's a that's a false
equation oh really
it's called it's called you being a
hypocrite now watch this guys watch this
guys
says and it was preceded that God said
the Believers among them over the
unbelievers then the Christians
affiliated with Jesus
I still have something to say though
Greg
you're not gonna use him though
whatever
everybody anybody anybody else check out
yellow Lane if you want don't let the
Muslims uh lie to you and say no no I
can show you I can show you I can show
you Stars
make sure you read Gospel of Thomas and
Barnabas because this clown thinks
this guy is a Luna yeah guys showing
Christians the NIV that he is
because everybody's talking over us Greg
I'm asking you as a moderator can I make
the point that I was making tell 360
people how in the gospel of time is
Jesus on alive as a little boy for just
looking at him like the wrong way is it
okay can you tell everybody about it
I'm making a point though no he called
me great because earlier he told me his
first name so I total mine it was
nothing but just being cordial no
problem all right no problem no problem
yeah so hostile already
when a Christian knows your book better
than you I know it I know it's time
you don't even know your own book I know
it's tough okay
yeah
we're quick I'm God logic I'll let you
speak if you're not going to use that
you're not going to use that whack tap
Sierra that you're using and two the
other the other thing is why why do you
why do you claim to have your God's
Logic is it wouldn't that be like
blasphemy yeah actually it's not because
the he's full of himself the Bible
literally says the Bible says that God
gives us his wisdom so and we're
supposedly
on his understanding
is it okay if I make my point Muslims is
it okay that makes sense if you've got
Guru in wisdom though
just let him make it Restless
amen just let him make his point it's
fine all right make your point
um
what steps you are using what types are
using my name is
yes go to the left I'm not making a
tough season move your move your screen
to the left wallahi is
yeah it's just Restless man there's
nervous man
so so listen
now that we understand that Allah
promised to make the followers of Jesus
during that time and even while he's
away
above the disbelievers I need you guys
to help me reconcile this you would
actually have us believe that Allah
failed to keep his promise that he
failed to empower the Believers that
followers of Jesus
and Paul overcame overcame uh overcame
The Messengers of Jesus uh
Constantine the Council of nicaea
disrupted the message of Jesus you would
have us believe that at some point Allah
failed to keep his promise and the
disbelievers were successful in
distorting the message of Jesus how do
you reconcile that
perfect so guys he goes to event theater
where for example it says what it says
those who followed you above those who
disbelieve into today's resurrection and
it was preceded that God supported the
Believers among them over the
unbelievers then the Christians
affiliated with Jesus
peace be upon him we're still subduing
the Jews because the Christians were
closer to following Jesus than the Jews
and then it says until Allah sent our
Prophet Muhammad sallam and he was the
Muslim he was a Muslim true follower of
Jesus so God supported them the true
Muslims and gave them victory over the
Jews the Christians and the rest of the
far right the nasara the true followers
of Jesus not you you're not a follower
of Jesus you're a follower of Paul
your Napoleon
why didn't you bother reading why didn't
your brother bother reading uh
you just take him into fear and you
think you got it right
yeah let's go
actually you were the first one to go
David there
because you misquoted dude did I let you
speak yes but you misfortunately that's
why I went there have patience have
patience relax
oh my goodness
you quoted David kathir and then now I
showed you that ibika theater agrees
with me you're throwing it because
they're under the bus now I never
thought so you went to ibika theater you
went to ibika theater to try to
disprovements oh my goodness these guys
are so nervous it's crazy I didn't even
interrupt you I didn't interrupt you and
they have to continue to talk on my turn
but I know how this goes I'm used to it
you know I'm doing this with a smile on
my face so please reckons is or just
tell me that tell me that because
there's wrong tell me that every kid
there is wrong when he says that they
were supported in conveying the message
and spreading the message of Jesus and
tell me that he's wrong
the disbelievers actually
hey I gotta get to get the camera if
someone's eating bro
and that the disbelievers actually
successfully distorted and destroyed the
religion and so therefore they
overpowered Allah and Allah was unable
to keep his promise reconcile that for
me man please
I already did he answered that already
already answered yeah you're just not
listening yeah with all due respect God
logic he answered bro what was his
answer essentially you just don't want
the answer repeat it why don't you work
here I said the Christians were closer
to following Jesus than the Jews until
Allah sent the prophet Muhammad
the Muslims are the true followers of
Jesus I told you from the beginning the
nasara the ones who believed are the
true followers of Jesus why in chapter 2
verse
it says what it were they successful yes
they were successful so they
successfully defeated all the heresies
and the false Believers that came
against them no they were successful
over the Jews who who were the ones who
claimed on alive
were the Christians successful over the
Jews
were they
for the Jews were they saying were they
successful over the false uh
quote-unquote false Christians that if
it's not it's not talking about your
trinitarians it's not talking about your
trinitarian so what about the true
followers of Jesus okay good did the
trinitarians then succeed over the true
followers of Jesus
did the trinitarians succeed over the
true followers of Jesus no because the
Islam Islam still existed regardless
no and now he's back to them exist
Ence
this guy cannot even Define Islam
bro that's why he sees he's one way
thinking bro
number one but it says that they'll be
superior Islam will not cease to exist
that's number one number two the
Christians affiliated with Jesus and
they will support over the Jews because
the Christians number one they were
closer to following Jesus
the true follower of Jesus just like the
nasara were just like how we are
so God supported them and gave them
victory over the Jews
okay I'll say my final point and then
I'm finished just address my point what
I just what I just mentioned right now
address my point don't run from that I
already did I already did no you didn't
hey God logic don't leave bro no I'm not
I'm not ready
look yeah that's fair I'll stay I'm just
saying according to this God logic I
want you to I want you to I want you to
answer this right now I want you to
answer this let me finish my
no answer my question who are the true
followers of Jesus according to this
what does it say I can't see it
it says until Allah sent our Prophet
Muhammad Grant him peace and he was uh
and the Muslims are the true followers
of Jesus who are the true followers of
Jesus according to this yeah according
to that it says Muslims thank you that's
all
so so and it says when Muhammad came so
before so until Muhammad came uh there
were Muslims still existed Jesus no
Muslims still existed regardless but
they were not Superior they were not
dominant right Muslims still existed
were they done we're not asking if they
existed were they Superior were they
dominant yes they were Superior over the
Jews because the Christians believed oh
my god brother how you keep
flip-flopping who is superior did the
Christians
uh what's it called be superior over the
Jews were they Superior over the Jews
did they believe in word did they carry
on the message of Jesus
were they Superior over all the
disbelievers or just this this is
talking about this talking about the
Jews in this conference it says the
believer it's not make my skin bigger
it's not it's not hold on make my screen
bigger make my screen bigger hold on
hold on make my screen bigger so God
supported them and gave them victory
over the Jews that's the birthday juice
oh it's over the Jews wait what you want
to take up in kathir but you want you
don't want to take any other tests here
all right
silence you rap exactly bye
I was actually muted yeah yeah yeah yeah
who was it again over the who my my
question oh just answer me over the who
you you read it you read it early over
the who according to over the who who
did he who did he say over the who
victory was over who were the
disbelievers that that tried to unalive
Jesus who were the disbelievers that
tried to honor life Jesus you don't want
to answer the question bro nobody can
hear you God logic speak with you god
logic who were the disbelievers who were
the disbelievers behind that voice they
were the Jews because the Jews tried to
unalive him oh Omar you coming with that
heat bro you guys
who were the disbelievers just answer me
who are the disbelievers
come on God logic got your tongue now
right you guys hear me and my Audible
you can hear but you're you're speaking
like a low low tone like you barely
I know you're thinking is this is this
better is this better now we can hear
you okay good okay all right so so watch
this hold on
all right
yeah because this is what I don't know
who keeps on blocking this person and
I'm blocking but stop unblocking them
guys watch watch this guys let me show
you the hypocrisy of Omar this is crazy
I want them to tell me who were the
Distributors earlier
watch this earlier he quoted it and he
quoted this part of it because their
watch can I get the big screen please
you just buried yourself Omar
you didn't answer my question still oh
you'll see you're scared it's okay okay
no more you can't tell me who are who
are the disbelievers that is nowhere you
can't tell me all right no worries
and you'll never tell me you quoted you
quoted ibacca theater in chapter 61
verse 14 about the disbelievers who they
overcame right and who are the
disbelievers and this is watch I'm about
to show you where you quoted ibikathir
this is what you quoted
that's why I quoted it no I did not yes
you did you miscorted me
that's why I pulled up to begin with
this
and watch this hypocrisy he just buried
himself is it good okay he quoted this
part of Vivica theater where it says so
we gave power to those who believed
against their enemies
that is we gave them victory over the
group of Christians which defied them
huh
this is what Omar quoted earlier ladies
and gentlemen bruh but I know that Islam
is like a picket it's a picket religion
it's a buffet
one second that's such a relationship
s
so now it's not a reliable source now
watch the
watch Jackson
it says Visa Visa so somebody said so I
think it was Central just let him finish
let him finish ibika fears tough Seer on
this is not a reliable source so I never
said that so Omar when you quoted this
when you quoted this one of your Muslim
Brothers is saying ibika there is not
reliable
guys guys let me finish let him finish
it is not authentic just wait like no no
I what I said is look at the word it's
not spelled correct you're recording
guys just just let him finish
so we'll continue and they become and
they became the Victorious uppermost
over the disbelieving group when we sent
Muhammad
reported that IBN about said when Allah
decided to raise Jesus Isa to Heaven not
Jesus Esa to heaven
Issa went to his companions while drops
of water were dripping from his head
okay so he's just kind of like going
over this whole story crucifixion and
stuff like that all right go ahead bro
yeah he didn't even make a point now
watch guys watch guys how he was he went
to a different verse he went to Epica 61
14.
I went to 355 earlier I went to 355.
right there on 61. I went to 355. I'm
gonna pull it up right now I went to
355. I went to 355. because that's the
one that you put it on watch
this is exactly what I quoted earlier
355 am I lying look at this coward look
at this when Allah said Muhammad those
who believed in him also believed in
Allah look at the models you are look at
that now watch guys let's see who the
disbelievers actually are because you're
about to get crucified how I prevented
the children of Israel from harming you
so they were the Jews when you came to
them with clear proofs and the
disbelievers this is what it's talking
about while he was on Earth these are
the disbelievers while he was on Earth
afterwards is your trinitarian dogs like
Paul
finish oh wow how I prevented the
children of Israel Israel so good
harming you so so Omar Omar let's let's
reason together bro so you agree then
that the disbelievers were the Jews two
different times let me finish let me
finish so you agree then that the
disbelievers were the Jews and then also
later the trinitarians correct the
nasada the true followers of Jesus
listen to the question I I never said
trinitarian I said the true followers of
Jesus I'm asking you do you agree that
the disbelievers the enemies of the of
the Believers were one the Jews and then
also the trinitarians right I said the
nasaro the nasada were the true
followers I know so do you agree again I
don't understand why this going over
your head do you agree
that the disbelievers were the Jews and
also the trinitarians who worship Jesus
as God later on yes but you quoted 61-14
no you quoted 61-14 and you and you
tried to act as if it was while he was
on Earth but you misquoted it because
while he was on Earth the disbelievers
were who can you answer me
a lot of times Omar the the points that
you think that you're using to refute me
you're you you're literally repeating
what I said to you and think that you're
refuting a point I literally said that
the success of the Believers that Allah
helps them with happens both while
they're on while while Jesus is on Earth
and then also after he ascends to Allah
I said that so then that would include
that the disbelievers while he's on
Earth are the Jews the immediate ones
that try to kill him and then also those
who came trying to uh uh bring different
teachings like how you would save the
trinitarians for example so you have the
Jews who are the disbelievers while he's
on Earth and then you have the
trinitarians who you would say are the
disbelievers while he's ascended so both
parties are enemies and disbelievers and
both parties Allah says because it's
believe it's disbelief is period Allah
says that he will they will be
victorious over the disbelievers until
the day of Resurrection
according to you they're Muslims I'm
going with you okay so according to you
so here's the question to you were the
Muslims always dominant
right until the day of Resurrection have
they always been dominant ever since yes
or no and be honest
that's the true fathers of Jesus are
dominant it's talking about the Muslims
it's not talking about trinitarians and
like I said the Christians who
affiliated with Jesus look look you're
not letting me speak now you're not
you're not letting me you're not
answering you're scared to no more I
just answered the question well then I
answer would that answer Omar what's my
question bro what's my question who were
the ones who were dominant I said the
Muslims okay good so okay
look
not the trinitarians
no not the trinitarians Muslims are
dominant what has been the dominant when
it talks about the Christians when it
talks about the Christians I know I know
what you're gonna say the trinitarians
right just let me ask the question
let me ask the question what has been
the dominant belief
what has been the dominant belief
amongst the Christians who call them not
the Trinity Jesus what has been the
dominant belief uh so this is the
problem during the time of the Prophet
Muhammad in the 7th Century they
believed in Allah
the Christians believed in Allah they
call God Allah bro what are you talking
about we have writings from church
fathers the end during the time of the
prophets during the time of the prophet
and seventh century
they called it Allah Muhammad the
Christian Arabs called him Allah you
idiots listen we had everything the
idiot we had the Christian Arabs
Christians
you're mad now trinitarian Doctrine and
Arab Christians called him Allah now
you're trying the Trinity now you're
crying now you're crying I'm smoking the
fears before Bible girl Bible girl
you're mad now it's okay
you're stuck Allah supported the
Believers among them over the
unbelievers what does this mean the
Christians affiliated with Jesus the
Christians I answered you the Christians
affiliated with Jesus the Jews didn't we
have hundreds of years of trinitarian
Doctrine dogmatized hundreds of years
before Muhammad what are you talking
about who affiliated with Jesus who
affiliated with Jesus the Christians are
the Jews
the Christians affiliated with Jesus and
who are the real followers of Jesus
according to the Quran I'm talking about
history
according to the Quran
according to the Quran um
Palestine your mic is way low bro I
can't remember
according to the Quran what was the
belief about Jesus according to the
Christians the Muslims
did the Christians believe that Jesus
was God
there were Christians that believed that
he was God but then the true followers
didn't believe that they believed that
he was the son of God then asada didn't
believe that what was the ones who were
promised Paradise they didn't believe
that what was the dominant view of the
Christian of Christendom before Muhammad
hopped on the scene before before he
hopped on the scene it was uh the the
trinitarians uh the the trinitarians uh
the the trinitarians and uh afterwards
the Muslims were Superior okay okay
logic
[Music]